sommes à la veille du premier match de
la Coupe du monde de rugby donc je mets
mon protège dent de rigueur
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'avoir découvert je suis sûr que
vous le savez pas que Guevara était
rugbyman oui mais bon c'est une horreur
franchement non c'est vraiment une
erreur le mythe Che Guevara mais bon
alors un autre d'accord
[Musique]
moi je vais pas oublier
tu te mets le maillot et tout neuf t'es
tout beau qui se situe les amants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que nous sommes à quelques
secondes du départ de cette dernière
épreuve de la journée à un concurrent
américain qui a quelques problèmes ici
qui préfèrent repartir voir son staff
ici l'équipe nationale en pleine
préparation
[Musique]
non le palais de Buckingham ne s'est pas
transformé en chenil c'est un
rassemblement Royal Canin les amateurs
de Corgi ont perdu la première d’entre
eux il y a un an alors il se retrouve
pour lui rendre hommage
c'est très dur honnêtement parce que
nous étions là pour le jubilé de la
reine c'est très triste de ne plus avoir
cette figure majestueuse parmi cette
figures
il y a la reine qui vient de passer
derrière vous non avec toi
mémorer la reine qu'à travers son amour
pour les corghis sa trace qu'elle a
chéri toute sa vie alors nous nous
rassemblons cette année et nous
continuerons à le faire tous les ans sa
mémoire
depuis sa jeunesse Elisabeth II avait
élevé 14 générations de Corgi
de petits privilégiés qui n'ont pas mené
une vie de chien le chef cuisinier de la
reine concoctait lui-même leur menu à
base de boeuf de lapin et de poulet déjà
ce qui est génial avec Top Chef c'est
que ça te permet de te confronter à des
personnes qui sont vraiment super
talentueuses parce que non pardon là tu
parles Top Chef
je parle de personnes talentueuses et là
nous on n'est pas talentueux non mais
pour répondre à ta question mes
concurrents du talent on est copains tu
me tutoies on va bien s'entendre
Monsieur le Chef il est un peu il est
audacieux mais arrogante si un peu ça me
plaît
[Rires]
Michel Drucker qui lui a fait son grand
retour à la télévision il était très ému
dimanche prochain dimanche dernier
il pose fièrement devant sa collection
de soutien-gorge c'est devenu une
tradition dans les concerts de Drake
c'est fans lui envoie leur
sous-vêtements sur scène même son père
s'est prêté au jeu en lui offrant un
modèle gigantesque sur Instagram on
découvre que le rappeur canadien garde
tous ses soutiens-gorge en souvenir des
photos qui en font rire beaucoup ils
pourraient ouvrir un magasin avec quand
d'autres sont plus mitigés très chelou
ce genre de délire oui 7 septembre c'est
le patunday joyeux anniversaire bel
anniversaire Patrick bel anniversaire
Patrick
la tradition voudrait que
comme ça il a fait
elle est encore plus belle en vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans le rugby dans les colères a été
votes regardez cette image incroyable de
cet évasion d'une prison de Pennsylvanie
danello Cavalcante entre deux murs à la
façon d'un homme araignée avant de filer
par le toit l'homme et jugé très
dangereux il vient d'être condamné à vie
pour le meurtre sauvage de sa petite
amie sur place une vaste chasse à
l'homme et lancer depuis une semaine
individu était repéré vers plusieurs
reprises sur des images de
vidéosurveillance nous quittons la
manifestation car des individus s'en
prennent à notre équipe
[Applaudissements]
cet homme à droite cherche à intimider
notre traducteur
escorté par plusieurs gros bras et des
policiers c'est quoi le problème non il
y a pas de problème c'est une formalité
faut qu'il me montre sa carte d'identité
et puis ça nous est déjà tous arrivé de
de nous tromper de nom en évoquant
quelqu'un c'est pas bien grave mais
quand c'est filmé que c'est pile au
moment où vous voulez prouver un truc
c'est plus délicat
quand je critiquais monsieur
prédécesseur on me disait que j'étais
raciste alors pas du tout ne pas
d'amalgame et vous vous êtes qui vous
montrez votre carte d'identité
non ça c'est ma carte d'identité non non
ça c'est un micro seuls les gens
habilités on se micro
il se dit journaliste mais c'est
clairement un militant hindouiste je
sais pas si vous êtes au courant
je suis un peu juif
donc il est possible que je ne sois pas
là pour qui pour jusqu'à 20h30 20h30 je
reviens comme l'année dernière je mange
un bout scout ou un croquant je fais un
kiffe tac avec vous casse le jeune on
est bien ok non comme ça je vous fais un
petit peu ce qui va protéger cette année
les autres jours c'est tout comme ça ça
sera toujours ma Conchita OK
[Musique]
bonjour
quelle surprise
[Musique]
madame ok bon au revoir bye bye au
revoir merci c'est ça